you grew up in washington yeah but like
rural right
washington state yeah yeah you came out
what 15 yeah man yeah and you were like
very uh
nonchalant about it i mean you came out
and i would imagine when you live in any
small town
rural america i always picture it as
being brutal but you describe it as not
being all that bad in terms of uh
getting ostracized it'd make a better
story if it was
yeah it just wasn't kids at school
didn't bust your balls no
really no i had a couple hard religious
experiences what do you mean
um like i you know i was active in
in a church and stuff like that and and
uh i had a
pastor refused to baptize me but not
until my friends and family were
gathered to see the baptism
and so that was really traumatic for me
that set me back
pretty far isn't that insane a religion
is the one place you think would be
tolerant of everyone yeah refused and
and
like set you up so that you come down
and then he can give you a lecture about
how you're the devil
i would have thought that you know but
over the years i've really forgiven him
because i feel like
what happened was he panicked and ran
out of time
and then in the 11th hour wasn't able i
think he meant to
you know from from the top of the time
but it didn't happen and it gave me
huge huge tools for helping other gay
kids and gay people come to grips with
whatever their
their journey is when you are living in
a rural community do you even know
anyone who was gay when you came out
i never met a gay person when i came out
in my life so you must have been
confused at first you were like well
wait a second i'm attracted to women i
don't even know from this
i know and i'd never had a girlfriend or
even kissed a girl or even had a crush
on a girl or anything but for some
reason i just knew
you know i watched ellen degeneres come
out he was right at that time
and i remember i had a boyfriend at the
time david
who's now the father of my my girls
and i had a a videotape of his baseball
game david's baseball game and i
secretly taped the ellen degeneres
coming out episode and kept it for years
labeled david's baseball game so no one
would find out oh that's something but
it made a really big impact on me that
was like an
aha moment yeah it was an online moment
yeah
so you had no role models i mean like it
wasn't like you could turn to someone
and say i think i might be experiencing
being gay there was no one in school you
could turn to there's
no one no my parents weren't having it
it wasn't
it just wasn't like that you know so
what did you say to your parents when
you finally did yeah
i guess you come out to them who else is
there to come out i mean i really didn't
ever say like mom and dad i'm gay
i just started being really quite
militant about it like i went to a
barber shop and got all my hair cut off
i was like i'm doing this you know they
just they got on board real quick and
over the years we talked about it
incrementally sounds to me like you are
a gold star lesbian i am a gold star
lesbian yes you've never been with a man
well done to know that
i know a lot well done to know that um
like even
growing up and stuff in terms of
sexuality and being a performer
did did being gay hurt your career at
all
at any point when when people would find
out oh she's gay or or
did it maybe even help your career i
don't know it's hard to say whether like
being gay hurt my career initially or
just being awkward
with my femininity you know i was really
awkward with it for a long time really
comfortable with it now and i really
embrace both sides of
who i am and feel really integrated but
at first it was just like
really really awkward like i remember
the first time i got invited to go
to la and do a showcase like i you know
borrowed a couple hundred bucks and went
to the gap
and got like a red long-sleeve t-shirt
so that was my you know version of
getting spruced up for the showcase and
i don't i don't think anybody was really
into what i was doing in that sense for
a while